hey what's up guys welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you a quick um a quick little helpful
trick i've learned that you may or may
not already know that's just kind of
helpful if you're actually composing
something in microsoft word that you're
using a lot of characters now i was in
spanish class and i had to do a spanish
essay and i opened up microsoft word and
i didn't feel like changing it to the
complete spanish language and going all
the way back and forth and downloading
the language and everything like that so
i had a microsoft word open and what i
wanted to do is just have all the
accented characters like handy
so here's a quick way to have them all
up for you always um to always have them
and be able to answer them as quick or
much quicker than you normally would
have been able to i'm using what's
actually built into microsoft word so
here we go i'm just going to right click
on my desktop for this tutorial and just
go to new and go to shortcut
and in this new shortcut all we're going
to type is char map
c-h-a-r-m-a-p
hit next and you can rename this i'm
just going to rename it map and hit the
finish button
and all this is going to do
all this is going to do is give you a
little shortcut that looks just like
this on your desktop called map or which
is what i named it whatever you named it
that's what it'll have double click on
it and this is where you have all of
your characters if i scroll down here
you can see there's hundreds of them um
all these characters different languages
with the accents and everything so if i
wanted to use one of these um and say
like uh some writing something in
spanish like you guys watched my um
my google translations video if i didn't
have those accents imported i'll go into
this microsoft word document here and
all you would have to do is copy and
select it and then just paste it and
that's it
so um i hope you guys found this
tutorial helpful just a quick little uh
video for you guys i hope it was helpful
for you guys if you're if you're looking
to get a character map if you like to
use it go ahead and um thanks for
watching this video if you like what you
see here go ahead and subscribe and
thanks for watching my videos peace